you're about to listen to something and
you'll see how me and my crew here in
the room manifested throughout it
something that we think is a ridiculous
piece of content I think you'll be
seeing a bunch more is the reddit Q&A
session and I think we'll be doing more
Q&A sessions across other platforms and
more reddit as well over time I hope you
enjoy it
audio enormous ly passionate about audio
believe that podcasting and Alexa skills
and the Google home platform
I believe that audio is going to save
humans time which is why it's super
valuable and there's not only my number
one but my number two and three trend
and I'm obsessed with you need to get
your music heard so the best way is to
actually make good hip-hop music because
if your product sucks you're finished
but if we assume that you're good I
would reach out and DM on Instagram
every person that creates content and
offer your music for free to them to be
playing in the background so that you
can cite them their audiences awareness
to hear your music and for them they're
getting the music asset that may make
their videos better you have to bring
people value I let zero minute waste you
know one of the things there's a lot of
you know the type this part but like
this I guess is per day so just I like
the new faces like the thing that I
think you learned pretty quickly is like
wait a minute this is even more
ridiculous than I thought it's just
basically [ __ ] fifteen straight hours
every mid like where the [ __ ] is like
when did he drink water like when does
he pick up this like when does he eat
something I don't like your but I'm a
robot
I like the punch line is like like
that's it now that's my bar I got ready
to expect anybody to reach my bar but
the reality is the results are
correlated to the work do they have to
create
or themselves if they're that kind of
person you know I definitely maximized
my efficiency by having a full-time
assistant where I like was like where it
was or like I don't even I'm like I'm
like I'm a complete slave to my calendar
which I am then the boss of through my
assistants which then forces it to be
maximized every minute we there's always
something to do if they created if you
if you were watching a YouTube video for
11 minutes randomly in the day you've
already wasted more time than I have any
day for the last [ __ ] five seven nine
years like like that's it good I would
have gone out a couple times and hooked
up this very one serious man I'm pissed
Thursday night don't know what do you
rocks good you gotta say ah
I'm sliding into the Vienna for myself
that I have the stunning that my funeral
will be attended by far more people than
anybody realized that's for me for my
company that I build one of the great
entrepreneurial media business empires
of all time and for the world that it
continues to do what it's doing which is
that a macro it always always always is
better than it was the day before even
if the headlines trick you into not
believing that
it will be it will be far bigger than
most people think in five years billions
of billions and billions and billions
before going in ten years it will be
understood and the trillions and
trillions and trillions of business and
20 years I don't know but it will
probably start looking like television
which is trillions and trillions and
trillions of dollars but not as
effective as it's going to be over the
next 20 years it will be a mature market
which means it will be priced
appropriately or more likely over prices
to try as many things as possible and
get into the yes business instead of the
no business they decided what they're
not going to do or what they can't do
instead of focusing on what they could
potentially do some good-ass content
right we're going to be an awesome
podcast so podcast you know I'm not sure
what I'd really talked about college
ambassadors I mean the punchline here is
being like influencers with audience or
influence or attention is what I trade
on and so what I'm looking for is to
give that person value that they value
and to extract value that I value where
both parties are happy the thing I love
about influencer marketing one good
thing I love about influencer marketing
is that influencers go out to dinner
with their friends and they laugh that's
a person that just paid them three
thousand dollars to put a picture on
Instagram and the people that are best
at it go out to dinner that same night
and laugh that that person posted it on
Instagram for $3,000
that was [ __ ] cool actually I don't
outsource look there you go I have a jug
fully into it but intuitively medium and
edge William with the guy behind medium
is something I would bet on every day of
the week so when I get around to like
digging a little further my intuition is
I'll find something I like and
holistically I like medium a lot
actually it's one of things I'm most
excited about is getting that game going
again already good I can tell I think
it's so important if you can produce
quake written content I stopped because
I didn't have a writer on my team but
now I do a perfect timing I'm about to
[ __ ] explode on my blog it's a great
reddit question but a shitty question to
ask me because it's not something I
think I can actually answer I'm not sure
the truth is the reason I love to an a
is because I want to bring more value to
other people and a lot of people do QA
so that they ask them questions that
brings that person value and I think
that's [ __ ] up yes you can I mean I am
completely driven by the chip on my
shoulder as well I love doing it to
stick it to people who slept on me but I
also do it I do it for I do it out of
the guilt and the gratitude I have for
the talents I was given a hundred
percent I am completely and utterly
blown away
I just basically think I'm no different
than LeBron or Beyonce right I was given
something so real and so now I feel
guilty and grateful so I have to do it
or the game 100% I have to stay alive
Brandon more to keep W and
Warneke okay it is my best friend that
was the best thing I ever did at Wine
Library Atlanta my my on my home screen
is mainly social sites and and nuzzle
and my calendar and the homescreen that
I most wanted the collective home screen
of every 15 year-old in America what
does I want to know what one or two
things they're doing that I don't
understand yet that I can manifest into
theses that will bring any opportunity
much approached together that made a lot
of sense to me actually that was like
that was such a you know I react that
way that's sowed the truth moving on I
don't I don't pander to negativity I
don't care about money
I do recommend it if your ambition
speaks to it what I mean by that is if
you want big things you have to be able
to take the risk of wasting your time
because the upside is if tomorrow
snapchat comes out with a feature that
crushes it and gets super hot again
everybody who jumped off of snapchat
because instagrams story can be sad and
that's what happened to a lot of people
with Facebook Facebook kind of roll back
in like 11 you know and so yeah I
recommend it based on your ambition
based on your skill right if you can't
write then it's hard to be good at
medium and blogging right like but but I
I'm a big fan of buying your strengths
so whether it's audio video or written
word you got to pick one of those if
you're capable all of them if you have
the capability and the ambition all of
them what's so cool about that is my
actions speak to my to my words right
like look what I've done I took crazy
infrastructure over last year around
that now it took me eight years to be
able to even for the first person eight
years eight years I did everything
should someone call and I'm not one I'm
not against it but I sure don't like the
feeling of being vulnerable to a
platform it'd really suck if Facebook
decided tomorrow to make instagrams or
organic reach 1% not for me because I've
siphoned the value of brand out of them
I'm not at the mercy so I don't think
that everything has to be my email I'm
not at the mercy of the platform because
I'm not transactional I don't sell that
way it's not about how many bees
this photo is gonna get for this sneaker
shout out it said I'm Gary Vee I don't
have brand
I personally use doing by creating and
putting out and then watching what
happens I use my intuitive nature to
figure that out a lot of other people
use hard core analytics I believe that
analytics oftentimes tells you what
already happened not what to do next
I think the interpretation of the screen
and analytics and word of mouth and a
quick conversation my intuitive nature
is why I've been successful because I'm
feeling what to do next
not quantifying what happened before by
executing by spending all your time and
worrying about everybody accepting you
in the industry before you've done
anything and blaming it on your age is
horseshit I mean Kobe and LeBron were a
team they thought the NBA to pay
attention cuz they executed and other 18
years became standard high school didn't
it's just the [ __ ]
the quickest way to tell somebody is a
loser is if they're blaming it on
something especially rage by learning
how to say yes and no and what that
means is you're only a pushover if you
allow it I think I think my leverage I
think it's real two-bit leverage to be
able to give more and always give more
and always give more and learn how to
take not at the expense of the people
you're giving for you know we are giving
but to the macro of it all like the
overall Karma and practicality I'm
willing to give to somebody left and
right just because I know what they're
saying behind my back is most likely to
be quite positive that can manifest in a
different way it's not transactional
with them I don't look at anybody here
transactionally I look at it as a macro
No
very zero I'm uncomfortable with it
because I'm deadly competitive and I
feel like I don't want to be a hypocrite
and they pretend that I'm friends with
them
I'm cordial because I think respect is
real but don't get it twisted if you
compete with me I want to slice your
[ __ ] throat madam by not trying to
convince them just go to as many of them
until one of them just believes it
without you convincing that it never
sell people selling the unsellable is
the stupidest strategy of all time the
help of my face to realize how lucky
they are do they realize they should
start over
or how lucky they are they were forced
to start over at an age where Stella
[ __ ] baby
naina tell you know I've been hot on
this I know a lot of you guys know my
content like looking at you guys so she
knew what feeds in here if you guys suck
man if you guys knew that I actually
think you're my friend and we're the
same age it would [ __ ] with you at a
level that you would not believe if you
actually vote if you actually knew that
I just think like we're friends I did
normalized right like but I remember my
cousin is only 18 Oh Bobby right Jake
Bobby's my cousin's only eight years old
Ernie when I got out of school at 22
years in the liquor store he was the
manager and I can't like he was 30 I was
22 I thought this [ __ ] was so
old how my dude is [ __ ] old like
right so like I sit here and I'm 41 and
you guys are some of you guys are this
age and I'm like holy [ __ ] they must
think I'm so old I think we're friends
it's crazy it's crazy
what is it about you oh my the way where
I was going with that was then you would
kick into patients like you would buy
when I'm selling the line
if you knew that it felt that way and
you can do everything you want it hook
up with girls and have fun go to say
like if you knew if you knew that
doesn't go away it actually gets more
leverage if you knew you would [ __ ]
you would [ __ ] eat patients instead
of [ __ ] spit it out another sister
let's go around Tyler what crushed yeah
what about me frustrate to tell Tripp
whose temperature is so I said time at
yeah that's for sure
that I know for a fact so many I'm the
bottleneck person at Nam the bottleneck
and access to me is a real real real
challenge Thank You funny how you have
like five to the PSN hoes at 62nd
governor's yet someone on your team like
really living in one minute
I think exactly right though I think
about that all the time that I've more
time for things that perceived to be not
as important because I'm pulling from
opposite directions it's really
interesting how it manifests right it's
so [ __ ] counter cool everything's
counter doing it for most right it's
mine it that's why I know it's all
that's why I don't get hype to myself I
just got the wiring that just wanted to
go left when everybody goes right that's
it there's nothing else it's my normal
just like other people's normals like
this is what you do in the entrepreneur
is an article and everything you've done
is predicated on people on the upfront I
love that feeling man I love when people
think I'm wrong that's what I know it's
so [ __ ] right so leaving in my head
that's a million times you're gonna die
it's it was so funny that it happened at
one time and you guys see you guys saw
that clip talking about some I was
believing a conference it was a real
like [ __ ] like rocks it was first
time I've got my mom like there's like a
Beiber like that it was crazy and I was
leaning in the car and I mean somebody
even ran up to that so I like slid down
the window and she's like just three
words printed by I didn't know I was
like I never said it before like you're
gonna die and I like torch giving like
that's for because if you are done I'm
like cool great I go but I that moment
she caught like that I figured it out
that's what I believe
that's what I think is going to happen I
think most of us would agree thus the
pressures on to do [ __ ] real important
question here the same info that I have
actually right now or okay let's say the
bars if everything the same and I have
all my info but I have nothing I already
won because it's the IP in my head that
right what I would do is take what like
if I had no money I'd steal something
and then sell it on eBay or Amazon and
then use that profit to keep selling
like I would sell my way to six figures
and then start code storm on so funny so
I did write like I sold I sold and then
I started realizing wait am I'm bigger
than that I'm not just a sales person
I'm an operator and then I'm like wait I
mean I'm bigger than that I'm a culture
hacker attention I got something right
so I would kind of play the same
playbook I'd go to my Ross simplest
thing which is and I literally had zero
I'd steal something that's just the
truth for I probably know what I think
stealing I probably go to Craigslist and
go and see people putting out chicken
free right like just probably walk
around neighborhoods if I didn't have a
car because I know money I'll go really
wrong just go to rich neighborhoods and
walk around until I see somebody put out
something in the garbage it's worth
money
I don't know because I haven't had a
family session at a scale enough to
answer that question by having them come
two years so what I would do is I would
spend a ton of time going to appling art
gatherings or internet places where they
hang and I would listen and listen
listen try to find patterns of what they
actually go for I would also give away
my art to affluent people at scale until
the guilt of the free gift created the
leverage that created my first buying
customers this is a difficult question
without more context but I would say to
give an answer I would say start off by
doing 5050 they're just you know couple
months just to taste the results but
make sure it's obvious to you what the
results are that there's a lot of people
out there that like to read and that I
want people to hear my [ __ ] suck we
should do this again I mean this is
really yeah this is like yeah this is
rich yeah yeah you know we need this
matter
we should this is really I mean this
podcast podcast feeds this is [ __ ]
good right pick me up on Twitter right
now and just say it's good not even
hashtag but you can do that too might
help me find a music it's good I don't
really have that process you know like I
don't know poop shower to bring email
absolutely I do but like I'm like done
saying and like [ __ ] enough of that
soon as [ __ ] wasn't really a nice list
to build a successful business you have
to sell something either you as a coach
in selling your time you're selling a
product you know your song service like
whatever comes more natural to you
obviously products are the most scalable
because they don't require your time I
bet the people that I work with 100%
intuitively and then I judge on the
reality of what happens next
so as quickly as I hire I'm willing to
fire pretty quickly not as fast but
pretty quickly one trend that I'm glad
is over I'm glad that it seems that
people are no longer using tragedies to
build up their following count in the
early days of Twitter people would say
retweet this and I'll donate $1 to Haiti
or for every follower I get on Twitter
I'll donate $1 to the Manchester
massacre that [ __ ] used to drive me
batshit crazy but you needed something
as selfish and vain as a follow count
for you to do the right thing with the
quickest way that I knew that I never
wanted to talk to you again that should
still piss off
you have [ __ ] you need to be to be
like hey there's an earthquake in Haiti
super quick and devastating but let me
get a quick 500 followers on Twitter out
of it real quick and then I'll give $500
to Haiti a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
different people just riding the hashtag
just forget anyway I said I would give
away my apparel free at scale to people
that have attention like influencers on
Instagram will you be willing to pay
them if I have the money the big of the
influencer or more likely up today I
dominate it's just [ __ ] true
I mean I dominate I got a bike I say it
because I know it's true what's given me
more audacity to say it is a kid was in
a meeting at UTA who's a fan and they
were there for other clients or in you
know in the or or for UTA or the fun I
don't remember who was for I don't know
if it's Jessica will or I don't know who
what it was there for but they were
watching it maybe was of just a
propogate meeting I don't know but I
didn't have that context but they're
like hey we're in here watching it and
all these people like who the [ __ ] is
this dude he's a [ __ ] star and they
have no vested interest CA telling me
that cluster and dick [ __ ] to me was it
more so just people you brought on or I
guess [ __ ] we teach anything processor
no I [ __ ] dominate Bobby's Lennon's
if you think that you can come in and
save the day and your and the family
will give you the air cover and you know
what to do you go help the family
business but those are two massive
[ __ ] it's yes by the way by the way
on a very serious note I don't know who
takes a lead here if we look through
Andy which could be actually and I'm
going to just give it to you said
because I feel you can do even more and
you're crushing it but I just like
expanding rubber bands I think this is
so ridiculously good and I think we all
know this we need to do this a lot but
here's what we need to do I love Reddit
obsessed with Reddit but there's also a
lot of other platforms for Q&A an out
whether it's Korra whether it's like
these other media sites that are trying
to it get me the State of the Union by
the way if anybody's watching right now
actually it's look [ __ ] you said but
anybody watching a live stream right now
if you actually I also don't want to
make a bunch of people do the same work
how do I do that
J keep watching right now if somebody
catches your eye on Instagram that
really is committed to doing five to 15
hours of research against you know the
state of the union of QA on the internet
like where it can be done what's the
right way to landscape for the 47
platforms but are doing it where's the
upside I want to pick one person but
then I don't want to just get work for
free we're going to fly
person here in a jam with us for a day
as well so we can get way more value
than the five to ten hours of research
your call Jake benroubi on the random
it's like who yes who's who like who's
who's going to sell you Jake benroubi on
like the person that you believe will
actually put the 15 hours of work and if
you want to pick two or three people
Jake and then call them but like I need
it okay
she is the head of what most people
consider HR but we'll treat HR here as
offense versus defense
I think HR and a lot of bigger
organizations is like the people that
[ __ ] suction and like fire you and
like [ __ ] out of holders of the
politics and just like really work from
the CFO which means that money trumps
everything is a net
she's the reverse which is like the good
behavior is the lack of politics of
being a bigger man and woman the all
things that I really didn't [ __ ] about
she is the she's the infrastructure that
is built around because she's the person
that I intuitively trust the most in the
world to do that
time is the most valuable thing AI is
built on the thesis of saving us time
but the people that try to use it too
far and eliminate the human element will
lose I think it's the people that use AI
to get us to third and fourth this space
and then put the person in a position to
close it out that's what I think the
magic upside is ironically if you read
the Thank You economy a lot of that is
played out there six seven years ago I
just didn't have the foresight to
understand you want a I and things of
that nature
nothing but I'm motivated but but I'm
not looking for it but I think everybody
potentially can be a motivation right I
mean I think so many people feel with so
many adversities on a daily basis that
I'm motivated by people who can deal
with anybody on earth right now that is
positive that has a terminal illness is
the most inspiring verse to me in the
world every one of them it's [ __ ]
insane you know amazing that person is
not some what I've seen though
confidence can be siphoned and then that
leads to some variation of it so I don't
know if it's charisma and everybody
defines these things differently but
what I can tell you is I absolutely
watched in the last 20 years
the people that get closest to me
psiphon my confidence and manifest it in
their world and it's been fascinating
for me to watch seeing look at [ __ ]
Tyler the confidence to [ __ ] deploy
that statement with that gust oh he
didn't have that [ __ ] six months ago
you're like what about two months what's
that I'd huh I'll be working for you in
six months
did everybody see never like in their
heads
the hint scratching my intuition the
truth is I just felt like it was right
it was the right organization was one of
the right vehicles for me to give back
on the thing that I value the most my
time most of that had to do with Adam
Braun but it's manifested above and
beyond that see that was [ __ ] awesome
[Music]